Speaker 1: You know, one of the frustrating
things is that you have criticisms from the
American Right, which can be resolved by this
type of spending, but they also don't want
the spending. I'll give you one one example
here. They complain about high gas prices.
Well, let's get off gas. Let's go to electric
vehicles. They also don't want to subsidize
electric vehicles. They just want to blame
Joe Biden. That's fundamentally sort of what
it comes down to. At the end of the day, they
say that we need to deal with the power outages
that we have in different places. Well, they
also don't want to spend money reinforcing
the power grid in the context of climate change
because they say it's politicizing power and
the guys. We know how to fix a lot of these
problems, but they just want to complain about
the problems rather than actually fix them.
OK, so is this a win? Yes, it's a win. It's
a win. But to what extent is it a win? The
package shrink, shrinking down to one point
two trillion. Only five hundred and fifty
billion is new spending. The rest of it is
just funding projects that are already that
already exist. Not super exciting. The next
step is that Joe Biden is going to spend much
of this week making the case for that second
bill. Some people call it the build back better
bill. Some are saying it's dead on arrival
that there's no chance, but there's now another
bill. Joe Biden wants to pass one point seventy
five trillion social safety net investment,
climate policy investment, if you could do
all of that. Now we're really talking about
a more serious accomplishment. The House hopes
to pass its version of the bill sometime this
week. If that happens, then there will be
a question of is there any way to pass such
a bill in the Senate? It's really unclear.
It would certainly become a serious accomplishment
if that were the case and Joe Biden's going
to be in New Hampshire, Michigan and some
other places selling the infrastructure plan
this week. So if he can get that done in particular
before the new year, although a very, very
skeptical about that, we would really be talking
about a more serious accomplishment, but that's
what's in the bill and of course, implementation.
Anybody can sign bills. The key is in the
implementation and we're going to follow it.
You know, one of the most troubling aspects
of this cult that is the American right wing
in the United States is the degree to which
they abandon even their stated principles
that they claim to hold above all else. As
soon as it's not convenient for them to stick
to the principle, if I say to you which side
talks about being the constitutional side
as a matter of pride, it's the American right.
They say we are about the Constitution, we
are about the rule of law. We are about having
a country that is the image that our founders
envisioned and demanded and imagined and created
this girl and a little bit of that. All that
stuff. OK. But they abandoned it very quickly.
One of the most important aspects on which
the United States was founded. And really,
it's why did they leave the old country and
come here
Speaker 2: is
Speaker 1: freedom of religion, which includes
freedom from religion as well, but freedom
of religion, whatever religion you want to
practice. Donald Trump's former national security
adviser, the top national security official
in the country for a period of time, if you
can believe it, as scary as that is recently
said at an event called the Reawakened America
Conference in San Antonio, Texas. Insane event,
completely insane event. He said. Listen,
we not only if we're going to be one nation
under God, we need to be one religion under
God. What what what happened to the Constitution?
Listen to Michael Flynn, who appears to have
completely lost his mind if he ever had it.
Speaker 2: And he's in there talking about
the United States of America, right? Talking
about the United States of America. Because
when Matthew mentioned it in the Bible, he
wasn't talking about the physical ground that
he was on. He was talking about something
in the distance. So if we are going to have
One Nation under God, which we must, we have
to have one religion, one one one nation under
God and one religion under God, right? All
of us together working. What?
Speaker 1: What has he seen the constitution
has? Is he aware of the document, which supposedly
he and his ilk hold above all else, almost
like a sacred text? We have to be one religion
under God. What what are you talking about?
And Flynn has recently been really upping
the Christian rhetoric significantly. And
part of this may be related to there are some
QAnon people who think Michael Flynn worships
Satan. And in order to convince crazy people
that he's not a Satan worshiper, he's really
playing up the Christian dogma, and it's leading
to him being particularly unhinged lately.
And remember, this was the top national security
official of the United States at one point
in time at this same event. He also had very
wacky things to say about Nancy Pelosi, and
he's just like off the rails with very weird
religious stuff. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: And that's a great song. If you
listen to the words it really does, it talks
about, we're not going to take it anymore.
The American people are not going to take
it. I literally and I'll probably I hope that
they run the hit tonight because I just did
a a a media hit with Tucker Carlson for his
show this evening.
Speaker 1: Crowd likes Tucker.
Speaker 2: Yeah, and my message, my message
we talked about, you know, this nonsense going
on without what I call the the insurrection
crucifixion. And and Nancy Pelosi is the Pontious
pilot. She's a punch ass pilot, aren't just
pilot, and this is a crucifixion of our First
Amendment. Freedom to speak, freedom to peaceably
assemble. I mean, it's unbelievable. It's
unbelievable. And 40 fact it's been over 40
years. Over 40 years. We've never had one
person, not one person held in contempt or
indicted for contempt of Congress in over
40 years to include a former attorney general
of the United States by the name of Eric Holder.
And of course, today, if you saw you're watching
the media,
Speaker 1: OK, so as you can tell, completely
unhinged, like how is there not an investigation
going on into Michael Flynn? And remember
that he was indicted and then pardoned by
Donald Trump. And also remember that shortly
after being pardoned, he called for a straight
up coup like in Myanmar, which in this bizarre
clip from the Forgotten Country event was
referred to as M.R. by a guy on stage. Remember
this crazy incident?
Speaker 2: A simple marine. I want to know
was what happened in Myanmar? Can't happen
here. Oh, oh. You know, there's no reason
that you should have a new reason for it.
Speaker 1: That's right. So there's Michael
Flynn saying there's no reason why we shouldn't
have a coup, just like they did in M.R., which
of course, is Myanmar. The guy you mentioned,
it has no idea what's going on, so extremely
disturbing behavior for Michael Flynn and
probably someone that should be on the radar
of law enforcement. But he seems to really
have lost his mind. We're going to take a
quick break. We have such a packed show for
you today. Let me know what's on your mind.
You can follow me on Twitter at David Pakman
and we will be right back. Remember that the
David Pakman show is primarily funded by viewers
and listeners like you. We have a membership
program on our website. We include an extra
show every single day for our paid subscribers,
and we offer commercial free audio and video
feeds of The Daily Show for our members. We
give priority access during our viewer town
halls. The next, which will be in a couple
of weeks, haven't finalized the date, but
I will let you know very, very soon. There's
the members only newsletter and so many other
great things. Sign up at Join Packman dot
com. You can use the coupon code felony 21
to get a discount. It's such a big discount
it should be a felony, but it's not. And you
can sign up at join Packman dot com.